[Musique]
bonjour Hélène bonjour Damien à la une
de la presse ce matin à ses réactions au
vote à l'Assemblée générale de l'ONU
votre qui condamne les annexions
illégales russes en territoire ukrainien
140 voix 143 voies pour 5 contre et 35
abstention dont la Chine est l'Inde le
journal français Lacroix évoque une
large condamnation de l'annexion russe
avec un soutien de la Russie qui s'est
très légèrement érodé par rapport au
vote de mars dernier avec deux voies de
plus contre Moscou le quotidien belge Le
Soir par le lui d'un soutien à l'Ukraine
franc et massif de la part des Nations
Unies évidemment dont le vote dénonce
sans équivoque je cite la Russie et juge
contraire donc au droit international la
tenue de référendum dans les territoires
annexés et c'est le même son de cloche
qui est à lire ce matin du côté du
Frankfurter alguemines pour le quotidien
allemand le message à Vladimir Poutine
difficilement pu être plus clair bien
que le vote de l'ONU ne soit pas
contraignant il constitue un signal
clair pour la Russie que l'Alliance
Internationale contre Poutine se
renforce après chaque mois de guerre
après chaque crime de guerre commis en
Ukraine estime le quotidien allemand les
parallèlements donc à ce vote des
Nations Unies du côté l'OTAN on
reconnaît que fournir à l'Ukraine des
systèmes de défense à Tiersen et
désormais la plus haute priorité les
Tribune de Genève explique que Kiev a
besoin d'un bouclier de fer pour se
protéger des missiles russes qui
s'abattent sur le pays depuis
l'explosion du pont de Crimée d'après le
quotidien Suisse l'Allemagne a déjà
livré un premier système de défense et
d'autres alliés devraient suivre
rapidement bref ce ne serait qu'une
question de temps de Financial Times
quotidien britannique confirme les
premières livraisons allemandes mais il
fait état lui deux difficultés chez les
alliés pour sécuriser les systèmes
Ukrainiens de défense aérienne d'A
quotidien britannique l'authentique
avoir des problèmes
d'approvisionnement liés à des pénuries
au niveau de la production mais
également à des niveaux de stock
relativement bas en France on l'a
entendu Emmanuel Macron s'est engagé
hier à livrer des radars des systèmes et
des missiles à l'armée
ukrainienne tout en assurant ne pas
vouloir fermer la porte à un éventuel à
une éventuelle reprise du dialogue avec
Moscou quand Kiev évidemment
l'estimement possible et c'est une
option que de ma scottime quotidien
russe indépendance semble envisager
également le quotidien qui juge que
Moscou je cite n'a ni les réserves ni
les ressources pour changer la situation
sur le terrain assure que le Kremlin
veut revenir au négociations en tout cas
telle qu'elles étaient jusqu'à ce
qu'elle s'effondre à la mi-avril en
espérant que la menace nucléaire
obligera Washington à intervenir et à
gelé le conflit avec les gains
territoriaux russes actuels Hélène à la
Une également ce matin il y a des
révélations de melapa de Mediapart sur
l'utilisation de de troll sur Twitter
par l'utilisation par la Russie non par
le PSG pour servir ses intérêts même en
prenant pour cible des médias et même
ses propres joueurs donc il y a Mbappé
française qui évoque l'incroyable
machine à calomnier du PSG actuellement
dirigé par le cathari Nasser El Khlifi
cette armée de faux comptes Twitter
aurait selon Mediapart mené je cite des
campagnes violentes et hors-durières
contre les opposants du club le site
d'info dit s'être procuré un rapport de
l'agence digitale big brothers comme
dans le roman de George Orwell ça ne
s'invente pas une entreprise de
communication numérique contrôlée par un
homme d'affaires Franco-Tunisien et
employé par le PSG entre 2018 et 2020
cette entreprise qui s'apparente plutôt
en réalité à une officine aurait donc
supervisé une armée de troll vous l'avez
évoqué attaquant star du PSG Kylian
Mbappe aura été visé en ce qui le
concerne et ce après les premières
rumeurs sur son éventuel départ pour le
Real Madrid en 2019 également dans le
collimateur de ces trolls le quotidien
sportif L'Équipe relie la campagne de
dénigrement dont il a été l'objet à deux
une qu'il avait publié la première sur
l'ouverture d'une enquête judiciaire
pour des soupçons de trucages lors d'un
match de Ligue des Champions entre le
PSG et l'Étoile rouge de Belgrade
c'était en octobre 2018 et la seconde en
décembre de la même année sur les
risques pour le PSG de devoir se séparer
de deux de ces stars Neymar ou toujours
Kylian Mbappé en cas de sanctions pour
violation du fair-play financier
avant de vous dire à tout à l'heure
Damien je vous propose de partager avec
vous cette info qu'on a trouvé dans la
revue scientifique Nature qui importe
que des scientifiques ont réussi à
implanter un genre de cellules cérébrale
humaine qu'on appelle
organoïde chez deux jeunes rares pour
mieux étudier certaines
maladies mentales certains troubles
psychiatriques comme la schizophrénie
cette nouvelle constitue évidemment un
espoir pour la recherche
l'expérimentation de nouveaux traitement
mais aussi elle pose évidemment un
certain nombre de questions éthiques
certains craignent que la création
d'hybrides rongeurs humains puissent
nuire aux animaux ou créer des animaux
dotés de cerveaux semblables à ce
cerveau des hommes ce serait une
catastrophe évidemment oui je suis pas
sûr que ce soit très bon pour les
animaux de réfléchir comme des humains
vu ce qu'on leur fait merci beaucoup
Hélène pour cette revue de